I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense it kind of leads me to something
else that I read that you take some
vegetarian days yes and like I look at
that as taking care of not your
community but the world on some level so
what are your I mean what are your what
is your what do you eat and and why do
you do that well I I think actually my
wife has been hugely influential she she
grew up in Ethiopia but she also grew up
in Holland so we so she was raised based
on a spiritual compass through food
right so the Ethiopian calendar has 200
days of fasting which is very rigid
right 200 days of fasting doesn't mean
you don't eat it but what came out of
that for us was how do you find a middle
that make sense of being a chef and
getting the right energy and so on so I
just like well you know what two days a
week let's just eat vegetables you know
whether it's a grilled cauliflower
whether that is mushrooms whether there
are whether that's you beautiful ramen
with leftover vegetables and there's so
many incredible beautiful grains and
vegetables that we can celebrate and get
that umami get that content that you
want so I never felt like I was
sacrificing anything it was just like
you know roasting a pair of roasting a
little bit of Brussels in the middle of
winter and getting that cool beautiful
texture on it so it's more like that's a
chef yes I should be able to do that and
do I really need to have that me six
days a week or whatever you really like
you don't and and it was it was it's
been part of the process now maybe 10
years for for me and you just feel so is
that consistent then for 10 years yes
has it grown do you do more days like
that or I also we survived there are
some dates where it's impossible right
because on the show we a lot and I can't
be the guy saying no I'm not gonna have
that I have to put myself out there but
coming if we shoot 10 day straight I
can't wait to go in a minute yeah take a
break and maybe do four days straight
yeah
plan and and you come out of it feeling
okay this is better so what do you think
from an ethical standpoint I think that
what I love about the generation of
chefs coming out now with more access
whether it's Internet social media your
starting point is to do better with the
ingredients right when I started cooking
was by the best ingredients use the
middle parts where everything else away
that's how you get to the fastest way to
get to the stars that it is a path but
it's not the right way and as a chef
you've realized that but why are you
throwing all this weight things away and
especially when you know that people are
starving all that stuff so I'm a food
hoarder so yeah okay I'll travel around
the world I'm like ups to out my
spaghetti squash yeah exactly
and it's good and and so and I also has
a chef you realized with the platform
you can you have something to say about
it so I'm part of a the eat conference
in Stockholm when we think about we sort
of it's a gather forum where we meet
every year about how do we how do we
come up better ways to cook how do we
come up how do we challenge the
purveyors more how do we challenge the
chef's more so there is things you can
do and as a chef it's part of it's part
of your responsibility
[Music]